>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Carla Hayden: I'm
the Library in Congress.
And as you could tell I'm a little
excited about our program today
because we have a very,
very special guest.
Many of you have met him
and you notice he has a
medal around his neck.
A gold medal because
he is the Librarian
of Congress's Youth Ambassador
for Young People's Literature.
And that's very similar to
being an Olympic medal winner.
He won what's something that's
called the MacArthur Genius Award.
Which is really like that.
I know. [laughs] Yes.
Yes. Now can anybody,
and I know some
of you have read his graphic books.
Tell me his name.
>> Gene Yang.
>> Carla Hayden: Yes.
Say it loud.
>> Gene Yang.
>> Carla Hayden: Give her the --
[laughs]
>> Carla Hayden: Louder.
>> Gene Yang.
>> Carla Hayden: Yay.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: And there he is.
As you know he's gotten lots
of awards as I just mentioned.
He's even had a chance
to draw Superman.
And if you don't know his story,
he started drawing comic books
when he was right around your age.
And he has traveled around the
country talking about books
and reading and reading
without walls.
And he wants everyone and
that's where we're going to talk
about today to read a book that
you normally wouldn't read.
How many of you read
something not just for school,
but a book that you look
at and you say I don't know
if I really want to read this?
Ooh. Quite a few.
Well we're going to
take the challenge.
So I want to thank some people
for making this possible.
And I had to write it down
to make sure I didn't forget.
And it's the Children's Book Council
and Every Child or Reader Foundation
for their support of us being here.
And also McMillan for a second
publishing for their help.
So now I'm going to bring up our
award winning ambassador, Gene Yang.
[ Applause ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Hayden.
Good morning.
>> Carla Hayden: Good morning.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank
you all for being here.
It's such a thrill
to be in this room
with all these people
who love books.
It's like one of my
favorite kinds of settings.
Well the way we're going to start
this morning off is Dr. Hayden
and I are going to ask each other
questions, mostly about books
and then towards the end we'd like
to get some questions from you.
So if questions pop up in your head
in the beginning, save
those questions.
File them away in the
back of your head.
At the end we want to
hear those questions.
What I'd like to first hear about
is how you fell in love with books.
>> Carla Hayden: Well, I
had the wonderful experience
of having people around
me who loved to read.
And one of the first things
they would do when I would go
and visit my grandparents
in the summer
and things is they would read to me.
And the first thing I wanted to
do though was learn how to read.
Read my own stuff.
It was nice being read to.
I loved it, but I couldn't wait to
start reading myself, so I could get
into it and read whatever
I wanted to.
I liked crime books.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
You liked crime books?
Like books about people
doing bad things?
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
So [laughs] I found this book,
my grandmother, nice little lady
and everything, but she kinda liked
mysteries and things like that.
And so she had this book that I
knew I wasn't supposed to look at.
It was called Hollywood Babylon.
How many of you all
know what Babylon is?
It was a wild place.
Back in the ancient days.
[laughs] And Hollywood,
you know where that is.
And it was a true crime thing.
Right. With all these
gruesome pictures.
Fatty Armbuckle.
Just murders and stuff.
And when I would come, you know,
she'd make sure she
would put it away
and of course I've spent
most of my summer finding it.
[ Laughs ]
And that's how I got
hooked and I said, boy.
So at first I could just look at
the pictures that were really,
really gruesome, and then I
want to know what it said.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And that's
what got you at true crime.
>> Carla Hayden: True crime.
>> Gene Luen Yang: True
crime what's got Dr. Hayden.
>> Carla Hayden: That's
what got me going.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's great.
That's great.
Well for me I grew up
in a house of stories.
My parents were both immigrants.
My mom was born in Meiman, China.
My dad in Taiwan.
They both came to the United
States for college and met,
fell in love, got married, had me.
I grew up listening
to their stories.
Both my mom and my dad
loved to tell stories.
I think this is actually true
of a lot of immigrant families.
A lot of parents who are from
another country or another culture,
they'll want to tell their kids
stories, from that country,
from that culture as a way
of building that connection.
So I heard lots of stories from
Chinese cultural when I was a kid.
But reading for me was
actually kind of hard.
I remember in early elementary
school my teachers would divide us
into these two groups, right.
And they would name them.
I think they're named
after like colors.
I think one of them was
like a red group or one
of them was a blue group.
But really they were the
fast and slow readers.
Everybody knew, the colors
weren't fooling anybody.
And I was definitely
always on the slow side.
At the very end of every month
our teacher would make us line
up by how many pages
we'd read that month.
>> Carla Hayden: Awe.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And I was always
either last or second to last.
It was like me and my best
friend would trade places.
But and eventually
the way I kind of got
through that was my mom would
sit down and read to me.
She would read with me.
Even now though, I'm
not a fast reader,
but I do realize you
don't have to read fast
in order to love books, right?
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
You just have to read.
It doesn't matter how
quickly or slowly you do it.
You could still enjoy the book.
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
And sometimes you want to read
slow so you can get what you want
out of it or everything like that.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: And it pains
me sometimes to hear people
of your age group and
certainly in my age group
where it made reading not fun.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: And
that's what the cool thing
about reading is it's fun,
but to have to go through all
that it takes a little bit from it.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Yeah, yeah, it does.
It does. I think there are ways
in which learning to enjoy reading
in the beginning can make it so
that you can get through some things
that are more difficult
to read later right?
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Because
you remember the fun
and that'll push you through some
of the harder stuff that you have
to read as you get older.
>> Carla Hayden: That's why when
people say, "Oh, we're going to read
to babies and little
kids and everything,"
that's to get them ready because
they know there's something good
if you figure out what
all this text is.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: If you figured out
you know there's a secret in there.
There's something that's really
cool in there and it gives you that.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Yeah. So you love that
true crime book as a kid.
Were there any other favorites?
>> Carla Hayden: I still have it.
[ Laughs ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: Were
there any other favorites?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, Little Women.
I liked that, Louisa May Alcott.
And the one that I brought up
here today is my all time favorite
when I was a little girl
called, Bright April.
It was the first book that I learned
about and you see I have my Reading
Without Walls bookmark,
so take that when you get.
The first one -- oh,
the Walter Award too.
The first book that I checked out
over and over and over to the point
that I had library fines.
And didn't even realize it
because this book was the first
book that I saw myself in.
It was a little girl who had
pigtails, who was a Brownie,
and she brown just like
me and when I'm, you know,
I'm quite a bit older
than you, Gene.
And when I was coming up
there weren't many books
that portrayed people
that looked like me.
Much less talked about my
history or anything like that.
And I just to this day
I just love this book,
because I could see
myself in something
that was important, like books.
If books are important,
but you don't see yourself
in them, what does that say?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
I had a I had a similar issue.
It was very hard when I was a kid to
find characters who looked like me
in the books that I was reading
and in the television
shows that I was watching.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And I wonder
if that's why I drifted
towards superhero comics.
I started reading superhero
comics when I was in fifth grade.
The very first superhero comic that
I bought was an issue of Superman.
It was with Superman
and the atomic knights.
Do you all know who
the atomic knights are?
They're a little bit more
obscure, but they're these dudes --
>> Carla Hayden: There's
an older gentleman.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes, yes.
[laughs] The nerds have
just outted themselves.
>> Carla Hayden: That's right.
>> Gene Luen Yang: If you know
who the atomic knights are,
you're definitely a nerd.
But there are these dudes who
dressed up in medieval style armor,
and they ride around on
these giant mutated dogs.
>> Carla Hayden: Ooh.
>>>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
It was kind of awesome.
I got to say it was kind of awesome.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: But I wonder
if I drifted towards superheroes
because I had a hard time finding
characters who looked like me.
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Because superheroes,
people don't realize this, but
almost every major superhero
out there, you know, Superman,
Batman, Iron Man, The Hulk,
they're all created by
children of immigrants.
They're all created by the sons
of Jewish immigrants from Europe.
And I think that's why
every superhero has
like these two identities.
You know, I had two
identities when I was a kid.
I had one name, a Chinese
name that I used at home.
I had an English name
that I used at school.
I spoke one language at
home, another one at school.
It was almost like that.
It was like how Superman is
both Superman and Clark Kent,
so I don't even know if I
was conscious of it as a kid,
but that definitely felt
really familiar to me.
>> Carla Hayden: That idea of
two cultures and how you speak
and how you are at home
and how you are outside
of the home is a common theme
I think with a lot of cultures.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah
I think that's true.
I think, you know, I actually
think that's one of the best things
about being an American is that you
can be an American without giving
up that core piece of yourself.
You know, because America is a
collection of diverse communities.
And that's one of our strengths.
>> Carla Hayden: Someone once told
me when we were talking about having
and being in this country
where there is
so many people looking all types
of ways and just this variety,
is what if you only had one
type of ice cream flavor
and you could never
have anything else.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: Think about that.
>>>> Gene Luen Yang:
It would be terrible.
>> Carla Hayden: You may think it's
good now to just have chocolate.
>>>> Gene Luen Yang:
It would be punishment.
>> Carla Hayden: But it
would be a punishment.
And how exciting it is to
take, that's how I feel
about different types of books too.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
So was it your love of books that
led to you becoming a librarian?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, sure.
Sure. I had musical parents and
I didn't have musical talent.
[laughs] So I learned early
on, but I always loved to read.
And when I found out that
there was a profession,
something that you
could do toto introduce
and really get the excitement.
I mean look, we're right
here, we're stomping our feet.
We're talking about Superman, and
we're doing all this cool stuff.
And so when I find out about being a
librarian I was hooked on that too.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Was there a moment
when you knew you were
going to be a librarian?
>> Carla Hayden: Yes.
There was a moment
when I was working
in a storefront library similar
to the one when I found out about.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
Bright April back in
New York in Queens.
And I was working with a
young man named Leonard.
He was ten, and he
would come in every day
and I was a kind of apprentice.
I wasn't a librarian yet.
I hadn't even started library
school and he would come
in every day and just
sit next to me.
And I would give him stuff, and
he would draw, because of a lot
of the kids made fun of him.
And that and so just knowing and
putting the right book with Leonard,
and getting him to
draw and stuff was
when I said okay this
is this is cool stuff.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's great.
That's great.
I do think that maybe
that's the thing too.
Maybe kids who other kids might make
fun of often drift towards books.
I was definitely one of those kids.
I was a kid where other kids would
make fun of me, but I was also a kid
who would make fun of other
kids, so I was on both sides.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh,
you were a bull.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I was a jerk.
I was definitely a jerk.
People were jerks to me
and I was also a jerk back.
>> Carla Hayden: See they were jerks
to me and I was one of those kids
that all the -- I was wasn't one
of the cool ones and everything
and at the last day of
school I'd have to run home,
because all the cool girls would
say they were going to beat me up.
But I could run fast.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That sounds
[laughs] -- I couldn't run fast.
>> Carla Hayden: See, so
you had to fight back.
>> Gene Luen Yang: [laughs] Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: You
had to be a jerk too.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah,
I had to be a jerk too.
But I do think like working on
books, writing and drawing is a way
of working that stuff out.
Like if you if you have, you
know, problems in your life,
I think all of us do, writing
and drawing is a great way
of just figuring that
out for yourself.
I have a friend who's
an art teacher.
He teaches art at a high school,
and he says that out of all
of the classes that a
kid takes in high school,
the art class is the only one
where the subject is themselves.
They're trying to figure
themself out by making art.
I think that's true,
not just in drawing,
but also of any kind of art.
Including writing.
>> Carla Hayden: And
what about music too?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, music too.
>> Carla Hayden: And
stuff like that?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
And I think that's why sometimes
if you have things that are painful
in your life, you can find
a little bit of healing
by writing and by drawing.
>> Carla Hayden: So did you
and I have to ask you this,
so in growing superheroes and things
like that, did you get any revenge?
>> Gene Luen Yang: [laughs] Like did
I make up bad guys based on -- not.
I don't think I ever did it
consciously because I was worried
about getting in trouble.
But the very first superhero
comic I did was in fifth grade.
I did it with my friend, Jimmy
Kiniyoshi, who was half Jewish
and half Japanese and we were both
the comic book kids in our class.
So during lunch when our
more athletic friends were
playing tetherball.
Do you all still play tetherball?
It's awesome, right.
Except that I was terrible at it.
The ball would always
hit me in the head.
>> Carla Hayden: [laughs] God.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So instead
of playing tetherball Jeremy
and I would sit at the tables and
we would draw comics together.
Then when we give our originals to
his mom who would take them to work
with her, and wait until all
of her coworkers went home
and sneak photocopies for us.
[ Laughs ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: We would take
these photocopies and staple them
by hand to make our own comics
and we sold our comics
to our classmates.
>> Carla Hayden: Ooh, nice.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
For 50 cents apiece.
It was awesome.
We made $8.
It was the best.
Now a days if you want
to do the same thing,
you cannot sell for 50 cents.
Prices have gone up.
You've got to charge
at least a $1.50.
But it was great, it was great.
I think working on that comic
taught me how to tell stories.
Working on that comic
gave me a way of --
I was also a pretty shy kid too.
It was weird, right,
being shy and also a jerk.
But I was a pretty shy kid, so
working on that comic gave me a way
of expressing myself in ways
that I couldn't with my,
you know, by just talking.
>> Carla Hayden: How did
the stories come to you?
I mean did you just wake up and --
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
When I was in fifth grade I thought
I was kind of like a, you know,
I thought I was like
super creative and stuff.
And so I thought, "Oh,
man, I just woke up
and this character formed
fully formed in my head."
But then as an adult I look
back on the character we made up
and I realized, no, he was
actually just a rip off.
He was a rip off character of Robin
Hood, because he was all green,
and he lived in the woods and he
had a band of friends that he used
to call his merry men
just like Robin Hood.
[ Laughs ]
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah, I
think that's pretty close.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes, isn't it?
[laughs]
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's real close.
But we there was one difference.
The difference was our character
instead of fighting with a bow
and arrow he actually
had a discus of death
that he would throw
at people's heads.
>> Carla Hayden: You work
around a true crime fantasy.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
[laughs] A little bit.
>> Carla Hayden: So.
>> Gene Luen Yang: A little bit.
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
There's a little bit.
>> Gene Luen Yang: But you know
I actually think now as an adult,
even though that one
character was terrible,
I do think that sometimes
kids think creativity is just
like when you make
stuff up out of nothing.
But that's almost never true.
>> Carla Hayden: No.
>> Gene Luen Yang: You know, you
can't make stuff up out of nothing.
What real creativity is I think
is combining things together
that were never combined before.
You know, so if you love superheroes
and you take something
else that you love.
I don't know maybe like chocolate
cake, and you figure out a way
to make a superhero
based on chocolate cake,
that will be a really creative idea.
>> Carla Hayden: Let's
work on that one.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: I mean --
>> Gene Luen Yang: I agree.
[laughs]
>> Carla Hayden: It's something
though when you think about.
So what are you working on now?
What is the reading without walls?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: Don't forget
the bookmarks and everything.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's right.
That's right.
Two Januarys ago I was in this
very room in January of 2016,
and the Library of Congress,
Every Child the Reader,
and the Children's Book Council
they gave me this fancy medal.
To this day this is the
fanciest thing I own.
[ Laughs ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: This is as
bling, bling as Jianlian gets.
Right.
[ Laughs ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: If you want
to touch this, come up later.
I'll let you touch it.
>> Okay.
>> Carla Hayden: It's got
your name engraved too.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
It's got my name on the back.
>> Carla Hayden: I see.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's
got my name on the back
and they named me the
Fifth National Ambassador
for Young People Literature,
which just means
that for my two year
term, 2016 and 2017,
my job is to get both more kids
reading and kids reading more.
The way I'm doing that
is I have been going
around the country issuing
what I call the reading
without walls challenge.
You know, one of the
best things about growing
up is you all get to
explore the world.
That's like your primary job
right now is to figure out --
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> Gene Luen Yang: --
how the world works.
And books are a great way
of exploring the world.
So I want us all to read books
outside of our comfort zones.
Read books that are
actually exploring books.
You know, books that are not the
normal books that we would read.
So the challenge works like this.
You could either do
this as a community
or you can do this just
as an individual reader.
You set yourself a due date.
By that due date just
do one of three things.
Number one, you can read a book
about a character who doesn't look
like you or live like you.
Someone who's very
different from you.
Two, you could read
a book about a topic
that you might not
know anything about.
Something that you might even
find intimidating or three,
you can read a book in a format that
you normally wouldn't read for fun.
So normally all you
read are chapter books.
I want you to give a
graphic novel a try.
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: If normally
all you read are graphic novels
and comic books, then I want you to
try a chapter book or a collection
of poetry or an audio book.
Just try lots of different kinds
of stories in different formats.
If you really want to
go for the gold star,
find a book that fits all
three of those categories.
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So I've been
talking about this all over America
to different communities, and I've
really been shocked by the ways
in which readers and
librarians and teachers
and bookstore owners have really
come up and met this challenge.
It's been great.
>> Carla Hayden: When I thought
about you being here and talking
about reading without walls
and books that I've read
that at first I thought,
"Oh, I don't know."
I thought about the book Seabiscuit.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
It's about a horse and
I'm like I've only seen
in person maybe two
horses in my life, right.
A city kid all of this.
That wasn't it.
And it's all about this horse
who is an underdog and he was
like a half mule and a half this.
And nobody thought he could win.
And when I got into the book
though, I learned all about horses,
and that, but also the
spirit of the underdog.
And that's --
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: --
theme came through
and I turned into a Seabiscuit fan.
[ Laughs ]
And watched horse races.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's great.
>> Carla Hayden: Because now
I know a little bit about it.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Something similar
happened to me with basketball.
As a kid I hated basketball,
because I was terrible at it.
I had these friends
were really good at it.
And when we played -- it
was just like tetherball.
The basketball would find a
way of hitting me in the head.
So I hated it.
I didn't follow basketball.
I remember in college
I lived with these guys
who were huge basketball fans.
And we would watch movies,
you know, at home on our VCR.
You all know what that is, a VCR?
>> Carla Hayden: You do.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
It's like Netflix,
except you have to
have like these --
>> Carla Hayden: A VCR?
>> Gene Luen Yang:
That you stick in.
>> Carla Hayden: Thank you.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So watched movies
on our VCR and then when like 10:30,
10:45 came around they would
force us to pause the movie,
so that they could watch
sports highlights on the news.
And I was always so mad about it.
But a few years ago I started
reading books about basketball.
I read one called Outside the
Paint about the basketball scene
in 1940s San Francisco Chinatown.
I read Slam Dunk.
Have you read Slam Dunk?
>> Carla Hayden: I've heard of it.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's amazing.
It's awesome.
One of the best manga
series out there.
I read Matt de la Pena's,
Ball Don't Lie.
I read a bunch of books
about basketball
and that got me really interested.
And now I'm still not an expert.
I'm still no basketball expert.
Like when I watch a basketball
game now, there'll still be times
when all the action will stop on the
court and I'll have no understanding
of why, but at least I feel it.
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
You know what I mean?
I can feel the thrill
of the game now.
And it's because of
books and [inaudible]
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
And things that you
never experienced.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: But
really getting into it
and saying okay I'm
going to try this.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: I'm going to try.
Now, I noticed something here.
This easel with nothing on it.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
>> Carla Hayden: Were you
going to put something on it?
[ Laughs ]
>> Carla Hayden: I mean
were we going to actually --
>> Gene Luen Yang: We
could put something on it.
We could put something on it.
So what I was thinking --
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
>> Gene Luen Yang: -- we could
do is maybe we could design a
superhero together.
Does that sound okay?
>> Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: We can
design a superhero together.
Okay. We'll start from the
head and we'll move down.
>> Carla Hayden: Don't
forget the chocolate.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
Yes, maybe a chocolate
cake superhero.
>> Carla Hayden: You don't have to.
It's okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
So I'm going to start by
giving them a big round head.
>> Carla Hayden: Does the
head have to be -- okay round.
>> Gene Luen Yang: All right.
Big round head.
Now somebody tell me what's
on the superhero's face?
What do you think is on
the superheroes face?
Yes, that lady right there.
>> A moustache.
>> Gene Luen Yang: A moustache.
Okay. A mustache.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
Now, all right.
I have a little mustache so.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
A mustache and what else?
What else is on his face?
Go ahead.
>> A round top hat.
>> Gene Luen Yang: A round top hat.
You all are going with some really
nontraditional [laughs] superhero
gear, which is fine.
Okay. So a round top hat.
>> Carla Hayden: Are
they pulling our legs?
>> Gene Luen Yang: A
round top hat, what else?
What else.
Tell me about this character's ears.
>> He used to have like
little candles like sticking
out the side of his head.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Candles?
[laughs] Candle instead of ears.
Okay.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, you don't
have to go with the chocolate cake.
It's okay.
Don't worry, we'll just have
some chocolate cake later.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
So candles sticking out of the
side of his head instead of ears.
Okay. We still haven't gotten to
-- someone tell me about his eyes.
Somebody tell about his eyes.
Yes.
>> Glasses.
>> Gene Luen Yang: He has glasses.
Okay.
>> Carla Hayden: Some of my older
colleagues might remember Mr. Magoo.
>> [laughs] Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: All right.
>> Carla Hayden: Kind
of have a Mr. Magoo.
>> Gene Luen Yang: All right.
How about -- okay, let's
start moving down now.
Tell me about this character's body.
Yes, young lady.
>> A jumpsuit.
>> Gene Luen Yang: A jumpsuit.
What kind of jumpsuit?
Give me a little bit more
information about his jumpsuit.
>> It's orange.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
So I don't have orange.
Oh, I do. I do have orange.
Okay. An orange jumpsuit.
Like a tracksuit.
Is that what you're thinking?
>> Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Like old
school, Run DMC style tracksuit.
Okay. Let's do this.
>> Carla Hayden: Orange.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
A jumpsuit.
I have actually never
personally worn a jumpsuit.
So I'm not entirely
positive what one looks like.
Tell me if I do it right, okay?
>> Gene Luen Yang: So don't
jump shoes normally have like --
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, yeah,
coming out of the side.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Stripes on the side?.
Is that true.
>> Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Am I making that up?
And you want an orange?
We have red up here.
Is red close enough?
>> Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: All right, red.
So we'll do red.
>> Carla Hayden: Looking
kinda spiffy.
>> Gene Luen Yang: All right.
Then somebody told
me about his hands.
>> Carla Hayden: Ooh.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Somebody
tell me about his hands.
Somebody tell me about his hands.
Yes. Yes.
>> Tentacles.
>> Gene Luen Yang: What's that?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Tentacles.
>> Carla Hayden: Ooh.
>> Gene Luen Yang: You
sound like somebody
who reads a lot of Japanese comics.
Is that true?
There are a lot of
tentacles in Japanese comics.
Okay. All right, let's do that.
We'll do tentacles.
So I feel like we're
losing out on the --
>> Chocolate cake.
>> Gene Luen Yang: -- the
chocolate cake theme here.
>> Carla Hayden: But that's okay.
They can do something else.
We'll have chocolate cake later.
Because I want you to --
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
Let's do tentacles on one side.
Somebody told me about
the other side.
>> Carla Hayden: They can
have two different, okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
We can -- there are no rules.
>> Carla Hayden: No rules.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
When it comes to this.
>> Carla Hayden: This is good.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
Okay. Yes.
>> Wait, where is the
cake residue in his face?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Face
cake residue on his face.
Okay. We can do that.
>> Carla Hayden: Getting
personal people.
>> And they're like browns.
>> Carla Hayden: Cake residue.
>> And then he has like a brown --
>> Gene Luen Yang: Cake residue.
>> -- sparkle [inaudible]
to the face.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Does
that look like cake residue?
That looks like he just
has a fungus on his face.
[ Laughs ]
>> Carla Hayden: Excuse me.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
Face residue on his face and
then what was the other thing?
>> His hand is like
a sparkle shooter.
But it's brown like
sparkle shooters.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
A sparkle shooter?
>> A brown sparkle shooter.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
So I'm going to guess as to what
a sparkle shooter looks like,
all right.
>> A cake shooter.
The cake shooter.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Is this what
a sparkle shooter looks like?
>> No.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That
actually looks like dandelions.
Maybe I'll add more color.
It will look more like
a sparkle shooter.
Okay. All right.
So somebody tell me about his feet.
Somebody tell me about his feet.
All the way over there.
>> One is really big and
the other is really small.
>> Gene Luen Yang: One is really big
and the other really small, good.
Good, we'll do that.
And then how about his shoes.
What do his shoes look like?
What does his shoes look like?
Yes, young lady here.
>> It's one pink and one red.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
One pink and one red.
One foot is really big and
one foot's really small.
All right.
[ Laughs ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: So
here's a really big foot.
>> Oh, my God.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
It's like a clown foot.
And here's this really small foot.
And we'll do some laces.
And one is pink and
one is red, you said?
>> Yes.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
So all I have are red, blue,
green, and purple up here.
Is there an alternative to
pink that we could choose?
>> Purple.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Purple.
Got it. Got it.
Anything else you want to add?
How about a little animal sidekick.
Who would his animal sidekick be?
>> Carla Hayden: Whoa.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Who would
his animal sidekick be?
Yes, young lady right here.
>> A talking cheery.
>> Gene Luen Yang: A talking cherry?
All right.
Okay. We'll do that.
>> Carla Hayden: A cherry?
Okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
And I think we're pretty
close to being done.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, I
think there's some more.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
Let's do one more thing.
One more thing.
Okay. Let's --
>> Carla Hayden: Can they
have another sidekick
to go with the [inaudible]?
>> On his shoes add
cupcake boosters.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Cupcake boosters.
>> Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's amazing.
Okay. So what would a cupcake
booster even look like?
It would look like?
>> A cake with jets in it.
>> Yeah. It would be like --
>> Gene Luen Yang: All right.
I think we need one last thing.
We need one last thing and that is?
>> Carla Hayden: Hair.
>> Gene Luen Yang: What is his name?
What is his name?
Yes, young lady, right there.
>> It should be Jeff the Weirdo.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Jack.
>> Jess.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Jeff the Weirdo.
>> Carla Hayden: I think that fits.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Are you mad
at somebody named Jeff right now?
>> Huh?
>> Are you mad at somebody
named Jeff right now?
>> No.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
Jeff the Weirdo.
>> Can we have icing cake?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Jeff the Weirdo.
>> Carla Hayden: Superhero.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Who is a superhero.
>> Jeff the Weirdo.
>> Carla Hayden: Jeff
would attract attention.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Weirdo is
"E," before "I,", I right?
>> Yep.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's
one of the few words
that doesn't follow that rule.
>> Carla Hayden: Who said --
>> Gene Luen Yang: And how about
them having a cherry sidekick.
What's the cherry sidekick's name?
Yes.
>> Mr. Cherry.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Peep peep?
>> No.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Peep peep.
>> Carla Hayden: I'm not
sure if this is going
to get optioned for television.
>> Gene Luen Yang: All right.
>> Carla Hayden: I'm not sure.
It might.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So I will talk to
DC Comics to see if Jeff the Weirdo
and his talking peep peep character
could actually make their way
into the DC Universe.
No guarantees, no guarantees,
I but like you all
to give yourselves
a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: That
is truly a super hero
like I have never seen before.
>> Carla Hayden: Never seen before.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Icing cake.
>> Gene Luen Yang: What's that?
>> An icing cake.
>> Gene Luen Yang: An icing cake.
We'll have to add that
in the second issue.
>> Carla Hayden: Uh,
the second issue.
>> And a symbol.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Oh,
yeah, and he needs a symbol.
You're right.
And he needs a symbol.
So those are all things that you
have to earn in issue number two.
>> Carla Hayden: And that's how you
develop different issues, right.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's how
you develop different issues.
Yeah. Well, you know, I written
in two different environments.
I've written for graphic novels
where you kind of just make
up a story and you
tell it from beginning
to end all in one shot usually.
And I've also worked on series.
So right now I'm working on a series
called Secret Coders and I'm working
on a series for DC Comics
called new Superman,
about this brand new character, a
Chinese Superman in the DC Universe.
But when you're working on --
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, you
want to give him a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: But
when you're working
on a series there is this element
of making things up as you go along.
It's kind of like when you're,
you know, when I was your age
and I would tell stories.
I would just make it
up as I went along.
So working on a series is like that.
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
The Secret Coders,
tell me about that one.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Secret Coders
is a graphic novel series I'm doing
with a friend of mine
named Mike Holmes.
Before becoming a full time
cartoonist I taught high school
computer science.
I taught kids how to code
computers for 17 years.
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And I've
always wanted to take what I did
in my classroom and stick it
into a graphic novel series.
So that's exactly what
Secret Coders is.
Mike and I are trying to teach
kids how to code computers
through this comic book series.
There'll be six volumes in all.
Volume of three just came out.
We're really excited about it.
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: We're
super excited about it.
>> Carla Hayden: How many of you
know how to code or what coding is?
All right.
Very good.
>> Gene Luen Yang: A
number of u. That's great.
That's good.
>> Carla Hayden: Good.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Now
speaking of computers,
how do you think things are
changing for the library?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, the library
and the Library of Congress
for instance right now you can go
up on the website, and
we just revamped it.
So it looks much, much cooler and
you can download from thousands
and thousands of photographs in
the collection of the library
and use them however you want to.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Wow.
It's for free?
>> Carla Hayden: It's
really something.
For free.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Download.
And where are these photos from?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh,
they're from everywhere.
We have photographs that
tell you about history.
other people have taken
to show different cultures.
And you can just about
type any subject in.
And photographs will come so that
you can then download and use
in any report, in any art, in
any way you want to use them.
So that's what makes it cool.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's great.
That's great.
You don't have a favorite
photo in your question, do you?
>> Carla Hayden: Not yet.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
I'm six months in and I'm
discovering, so I'm Tweeting.
And every day that I'm here I put
up something cool that I found
and I've seen, like Thomas
Jefferson's handwriting
in his own hand when
he was writing the --
working on the Declaration of
Independence and seeing him
and what he put in
and what he took out.
I think people don't realize
there are drafts of certain things
that you hear about, but
they did a lot of cross outs
and thought about things.
And it's really nice to see okay,
this didn't come up just perfect
that they had to work on it.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Yeah. I actually think that that
was something that I had to learn,
you know, as I grew up and
started making stories as an adult.
When I was a kid and I read
books I always thought, man,
this came into that author's
head perfectly formed.
And they just wrote it down
and sent it to the publisher
and the publisher made
it into a book.
After I got it the books I realized
that is not the case at all,
that there's so much
revision that happens.
There's so much stuff where
you write something down
and you're not super satisfied
with it, you just change it,
and change it, and tweak it,
and tweak it until it gets
to where you want it to be.
I would say maybe even
half of writing,
half of making stories is that.
>> Carla Hayden: Is
changing and making.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: So when you
see that even the Declaration
of Independence there were cross
outs and there were thoughts
and there were things like that.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: And Abraham
Lincoln, the Gettysburg Address
to see his whole handwriting
and what he thought.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So even somebody
like Abraham Lincoln couldn't
get it right the first time.
>> Carla Hayden: Couldn't
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Had to [crosstalk]
>> Carla Hayden: But
he worked on it.
And the thing about Abraham
Lincoln that wonderful speech
that he gave was the
shortest speech that day.
One guy gave a speech
for three hours.
Can you imagine?
One speech, three hours.
And Abraham Lincoln got up and
it was five minutes and they said
that was the best speech of the day,
because it was short
and to the point.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
Yeah. Another thing that I had to
learn as a professional writer is
that often longer doesn't
mean better.
I remember when I was in high school
and I would write things
for my English class.
I would always try to make by my
sentences as long as possible,
and I would put in as
many big words as I could.
Like words where I barely even
understand what they meant.
>> Carla Hayden: Right.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Right.
And I wanted to do it because I felt
like it would make me sound smarter.
But now as an adult,
as a professional writer I realize
what makes you sound smart is
actually just being clear.
If you can say something as clearly
as possible, as simply as possible,
that is the best and
smartest way of saying it.
>> Carla Hayden: Have you
ever and a book that I read
that in a different format,
the Reading Without
Words is a graphic novel.
A Graphic March by John Lewis.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: About
the civil right.
Oh, you've read it.
Oh, good. Because I had never read.
Sorry, Gene.
>> Gene Luen Yang: [laughs] No.
>> Carla Hayden: I really
read a graphic book.
And I thought, oh, and then I got
into it and then I was like wow.
I want volume two and volume three.
And we were thinking and I talk
to you about a graphic book
about the Library of Congress.
What do you think about that?
Okay. Telling the story of
the Library of Congress.
In graphic format.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, I think
that's an amazing book series.
March. How many of
you ever read March?
Awesome. So if you haven't read
it yet, you're in for a treat.
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Go and
find it at your local library.
I'm sure they'll have it.
Read it. It's a nonfiction
book, so it's about real events.
It's an autobiography.
It's Congressman John Lewis
writing about his life.
I recently visited a museum,
it's called the Tombseum.
It's out of Pittsburgh.
And there they have a
focus on comics art.
So it's all these pages
of comic book stories.
It's pages from graphic novels, and
you can see -- it's the originals,
so you could see how the
artist actually draws.
They had an exhibit there,
an old comic book that most
of us don't remember, but it
was about Martin Luther King Jr.
And it was it was a 22 page comic.
John Lewis, Congressman John
Lewis when he was a kid he read
that comic book, and that comic
book was so influential on him
that when it came time for
him to tell his own story
about his own life,
he wanted to tell it
as a comic book as a comic book.
As a thick comic, as
a graphic novel.
So it just goes to show that
even things that seem forgotten
like that old comic book
about Martin Luther King
Jr., they're not forgotten.
When you tell stories, when
you release your own stories
into the world, you have
no idea how they're going
to affect people years
down the road.
>> Carla Hayden: And one thing that
you might not know about the Library
of Congress is that we
have the largest collection
of comic books in the
world right here.
Did you know that?
The first edition of
Batman, Luke Cage.
All of that.
Right here at the Library
of Congress.
And we are going to display some
of those things during Awesomecom.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
>> Carla Hayden: It's going to be
here in Washington D.C. with movies
and comics and all of these
types of things, and the Library
of Congress is going to
be part of Awesomecom.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's so great.
That's so great.
>> Carla Hayden: So [crosstalk]
>> Gene Luen Yang: There are
so many reasons why the
Library of Congress is awesome.
Yet another reason, the
largest comic book collection
in the entire world.
It looks like we're winding
down, so we would like now
to take questions from all of you.
We have a whole bunch of
students joining us from all
over the country, and unfortunately
those students are not going
to be able to ask us questions.
So I want to acknowledge
that they're with us first,
and then we'll take some questions
from the kids in the room.
Okay. So right now we're being
joined by Alderman Elementary,
by Valley Springs Middle School
by Saint Steven's Elementary,
Hopewell Elementary of Trinity,
Jacobs Fork Middle School,
Triad Math and Science Academy,
Saint Ambrose School, Norton High,
North Columbus Elementary,
The College of Education
at Governor State University.
And students from D.C. public
schools all around the city.
So thank you all.
>> Carla Hayden: Thank you.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Thank
you for joining us.
[ Applause ]
>> Gene Luen Yang:
So kids in the room.
What kind of questions
can we answer for you?
Yes.
>> Okay. So this question might
sound weird, but is DC Comics is it
like a building in DC, or
is it just called DC Comics?
>> Gene Luen Yang: That is not a
weird question at all, because DC --
>> Carla Hayden: Good.
>> Gene Luen Yang: -- name
is super confusing, right.
It's a weird name.
Marvel makes sense, I think.
DC Comics is a little bit weird.
DC Comics office building
used to be in New York City.
It was in New York City
for decades and decades.
And now it's in Burbank, California,
which is just outside of Hollywood.
I got to visit the DC
Comics office a couple
of times now, and it's
pretty awesome.
You walk into their waiting area.
They have giant statues of
Superman, Batman and Wonder Woman.
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Wearing the
costumes that they'll be wearing
in the upcoming Justice
League movie.
They have a chess set in the middle
of the waiting room that has instead
of the traditional chess pieces,
it's like Superman and Wonder Woman
and Batman and Joker on the
other side, really cool.
The name DC Comics it actually comes
from the very first
comic book series
that DC Comics ever published.
It was called Detective
Comics that came out in 1939,
so the DC of DC Comics is actually
short for Detective Comics.
Which makes it a really
weird name, right,
because DC Comics then it just
means it's Detective Comics Comics.
[ Laughs ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: But
that's just the way it is.
DC is as our oldest surviving
comic book company in America.
You know, like sometimes stuff from
the olden days a little bit weird.
Yes, young lady.
>> Were your comic books --
do you have like a person who
helps you have ideas for them
or is it you just by yourself
having the ideas for your books?
>> Gene Luen Yang: So the question
is do I just have ideas on my own
or do I have somebody
helping me with ideas.
And I would say it
depends on the book.
So when I'm writing for DC Comics,
the stories that I'm writing
are part of a bigger universe.
You know, right now I'm writing
about a character named Ken Enchong
who is the Chinese Superman.
Ken Enchong is in the same universe
as Clark Kent, as Bruce Wayne
as all the other superheroes.
So in that case I can't
just have ideas on my own.
I actually have to collaborate
with other artists and
with other writers.
But then when I write books for my
other publisher for second books,
most of those are standalone
graphic novels, so they're a story
with a beginning, middle, and end.
And for those I generally
just have ideas out of my own.
Sometimes I'll work with a partner,
but often they'll start
off as just in my own head.
All right.
That sounds like a
question from somebody
who might be wondering
where ideas come from.
Is that true for you?
Okay, so I get this question a lot.
Kids will sometimes ask me
where my ideas come from.
Often my ideas come
from my own life.
You know sometimes if you feel
like you have a creative assignment
and you don't have any ideas for
it, just think about your own life.
Even if your own life seems boring.
I guarantee if you think about
it long enough, it is not.
So for instance the very
first comic I ever did
as an adult is called Gordon
Yamamoto and the Team of the Geeks.
It's about a young man who gets a
spaceship stuck inside of his nose,
and becomes friends with the alien
that's living inside of the ship.
That book is from my own life.
[ Laughs ]
>> Gene Luen Yang:
I've always had --
>> Carla Hayden: Too
much [inaudible]
>> Gene Luen Yang:
-- sinus problems.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I've
always had sinus problems
and one day I thought
what if what was plugging
up my nose was a spaceship.
Think about your life long enough,
I guarantee you ideas
are going to come out.
>> Carla Hayden: I need them now.
Sinus.
>> Gene Luen Yang: [laughs] Yes.
>> How did you feel when
you released you first book?
>> Gene Luen Yang: How did I feel?
Like the very first book that
I released was in fifth grade.
It was amazing.
>> Like when you were a grown up.
>> Gene Luen Yang: As a
grown up the first book
that I released was Gordon
Yamamoto and the Team of Geeks.
I actually self-published that.
So I didn't even go for a publisher.
I just got it printed it up
myself and I tried to go to stores
and local comic book
conventions to sell it by hand.
And it was great.
It was a lot of work.
It's a lot of work to publish your
own comics, but I remember being
at a comic book convention and
handing that book to somebody
and having them hand
me a few dollars.
It felt great.
It felt great that somebody
wanted to read my book so much
that they were willing to
part with $3 bills for it.
It was awesome.
Yes. Young man in the front.
>> When did you first make
your first comic book?
>> Gene Luen Yang: When
did I make my first comic?
The very first comic I remember
making was in fifth grade.
The main character was
a rip off of Robin Hood.
It was a terrible comic, but
it was still fun to make.
>> Carla Hayden: [inaudible]
in the middle.
>> Do you have any more copies
of the books that you have
from when you were younger?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Do
I have any more copies?
I'm sure if I went back to
my parents house and I dug
around I'd be able to find one.
Yeah. Of that fifth grade comic.
I also when I was in
sixth grade I made a comic
about somebody who sold shoes.
I didn't even know
what I was thinking.
I mean [inaudible] a comic
by somebody who sold shoes,
and I made a comic about do
you know what the Smurfs are?
>> Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And you
know what the Transformers are?
>> Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I made a
comic called the Transmurfers
where all the Smurfs would
transform into a robotic fruit.
[ Laughs ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: That
was fun to work on.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
Yes.
>> So this isn't really
related to your book,
but what's your favorite basketball
team, if you like basketball?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
So the question is what is
my favorite basketball team?
I want to hear yours.
>> Carla Hayden: OK
>> Gene Luen Yang: I
want to hear yours.
I come from the Bay Area.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, I was on --
>> Gene Luen Yang: There
is only one answer, right.
There's only one answer.
I have to go with the Warriors.
>> Carla Hayden: I'm from Chicago.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
[laughs] Yep, there you go.
>> Carla Hayden: Drop the mic.
[ Laughs ]
>> Carla Hayden: The bears.
Oh, that's foot ball.
>> Gene Luen Yang: All right.
How about the young
lady right there.
Yeah.
>> What materials do you
use to make your comics?
>> Gene Luen Yang: I'm sorry.
What was that?
>> What materials do you use?
>> Gene Luen Yang: What material.
That's great.
Okay. So when I was your age
I read this book called How
to Make Comics The Marvel Way.
It was written by Stan Lee
and Stan Lee told me how
to use a certain set of materials.
Told me I had to use Bristol board.
Which is it's like this super thick
white paper, really, really thick.
So he told me I had to use
a certain kind of pencil.
He told me I had to use a
brush and a bottle of ink.
So I did. That's how I
started off making comics.
Then after I became an adult, after
I started going to conventions
and hanging out with
other cartoonists,
I realized that not everybody
makes comics the Marvel way.
Almost every cartoonist you
talk to they will have figured
out their own set of materials.
So if you want to make
comics, if you want to make art
in general, you should experiment.
You should figure out what
materials feel best for you.
Right now I am using a regular
number two pencil to draw.
I'm using what's called a blue
pencil to do my sketching.
It's a certain shade of blue called
non-photo blue and I no longer ink
with a brush and a ball of ink.
I actually ink with
a Japanese brush pen.
So I don't need that
bottle of ink anymore.
Yes, young lady with the headband.
>> What is your Chinese name?
>> Gene Luen Yang: My Chinese name.
So my Chinese name is my
American name is a transliteration
of my Chinese name.
Meaning my parents
picked my American name
because it sounded kind
of like my Chinese name.
So my American name
is Gene Luan Yang.
My Chinese name is Young Gene Luan.
Now that middle character Gene has
an interesting story behind it.
You know, it's a it's a Chinese
tradition to give the gift of gold
to babies when they're first born.
So when I was first born I got
all this gold from my relatives.
And then after I became an
adult my mom gave me this gold.
So when I got this gold as
an adult I looked through it.
And on one of these little
plates it had my name.
It had Yang Gene Luan,
but the middle character Gene
was a different character.
It sounded the same, but it
was a totally different word.
And I was like, I was like,
you know, my aunt who gave this
to me she didn't even know my name.
She got my name wrong.
And my mom said, "No,
she didn't get it wrong.
That was your actual name
when you were first born."
So I said, "Okay.
So what does this Gene mean?"
And she says, "That
Gene means splendid."
And I said, "It means splendid?
You named me Splendid,
why did you change that?"
[ Laughs ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: And she
said, "Well, after you turn one
and you started walking around
you kept hitting your head.
So we changed it to another
Gene, which means careful."
So that's what my name
means now [laughs].
It means careful.
Yes.
>> How many comics have
you made since you started?
>> Gene Luen Yang:
So the question is,
how many comics have I
made since I started?
I have made a lot.
It's actually kind of hard to count.
I did ten issues of Superman.
I'm working on issue number
13 of the new Superman,
so right there I've done 23
issues for DC Comics and then
for a first second I've done a lot.
I may be done I don't
know 12, 12 books now.
And then I've also worked on the
Avatar last air bender comics.
I did 15 volumes of that so far.
So I've done a lot.
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I've done a lot.
Yes, the man in the -- oh, yeah.
>> What's your favorite
book, comic book?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Okay.
So my favorite book
when I was a kid.
I'm really sad that it's
been a little bit forgotten.
So I want you all to try
to read this book today.
Okay. I love the book of three.
It's a series of books
by Lloyd Alexander.
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
They were my favorite.
As a librarian.
You must have seen that
go out a lot, right?
>> Carla Hayden: Lord.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Like my
generation loved that book.
It seems like --
>> Carla Hayden: It's been lost.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's
been a little bit lost.
>> Carla Hayden: Really.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I'm
trying to bring it back.
>> Carla Hayden: Good.
[ Laughs ]
>> Carla Hayden: [Inaudible]
Alexander, classic.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah
I love [inaudible].
And then in terms of
comic books, you know,
March is a really great comic book.
You all ought to read that.
There's just a ton of
comic books that I love.
I don't know if I can
pick one favorite.
I really do love Mouse though.
It's a little bit older.
It's a nonfiction book
about the Holocaust.
It's a really sad and
heart wrenching book,
but I think it's really
[inaudible] done.
>> Carla Hayden: And
then I have a question.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Oh, go ahead.
Yeah.
>> What was the first
book that the Library
of Congress had in their library?
>> Gene Luen Yang:
That's a great question.
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
I want to know too.
>> Carla Hayden: I don't know.
[ Laughs ]
>> Carla Hayden: The
first book there were
about two or 300 books in 1800.
And they were, the library was
actually part of the capital.
And they had books like the
Bible, and some other books
that they thought that it would
be good in dictionaries and things
that they thought it would
be good for Congress.
But thank you for asking that,
because I'm going to find
out what was the very first book
that someone purchased
for the library.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's great.
Well, can you give
us some highlights,
some of the highlights
of the collection?
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, my goodness.
Highlights.
Well, you have books that
go back to the 12th century.
You have the first
Bible right outside here
that was ever printed with type.
So the Gutenberg Bible,
that was something 1500.
And then you have books that are
you would call them graphic now.
Audubon books with the beautiful
birds and all types of things.
It's just there's so many things
that's what's so wonderful about it.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
It's a magical place.
>> Carla Hayden: Yeah.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Turning
lane feel the magic,
right, sitting in this room?
>> Carla Hayden: Well,
we were stomping around.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
[laughs] So, young man in the red.
>> Well, so earlier you were
telling me my friends about Frogman.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Oh, yeah.
>> So [inaudible] about Frogman.
>> Carla Hayden: Frogman.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
So earlier we were hanging out
and they were asking me what
my favorite superhero was
and Frogmen is definitely one
of my favorite superheroes is.
He's an obscure character
from the Marvel Universe.
And he doesn't have
any super powers.
He just wears a costume that
makes him look like a frog.
So his whole thing is this,
his whole thing is this.
He is the son of a super
villain named the Leap Frog.
Who use his frog suit to go and
rob banks, and then he finds
out that his dad is this criminal
and he feels really bad about it.
So he steals the suit from his dad
and becomes a superhero
called frogmen.
>> Carla Hayden: And
these super powers are?
>> Gene Luen Yang: His super power
is at the bottom of his suit on each
of his feet are giant springs,
so he could just jump around,
and that's his whole power.
[ Laughs ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: I'm learning a lot.
[ Laughs ]
>> Carla Hayden: It's true.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Do you write and illustrate your
books or does somebody else do it?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Do I write
and illustrate my books?
It depends on the book.
So there are some books where I do
both the writing and the drawing
and there are other books
where I only do the writing
and somebody else does the drawing.
I work with a friend of
mine who does the drawing.
So it depends on the book.
>> Carla Hayden: So we have time
for a couple more questions.
One more question.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
>> Carla Hayden: Oh my.
One more question.
Okay. So how about the gentlemen
in the glasses, sunglasses.
>> Do you prefer Marvel
or DC Comics?
>> Gene Luen Yang: I want to
hear -- I like to hear your.
Do you have any answer to this.
>> Carla Hayden: No.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Dr. Hayden.
>> Carla Hayden: I'm just
getting into it between Frog Man,
Jeff the Weirdo and some of the
others I have to start reading
and this is going to be
my reading without walls.
I'm going to get into
real comic books.
That's my pledge.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I'm going
to have to send [inaudible]
>> Carla Hayden: I'm going to read
and this is my reading challenge.
I'm going to and it's going
to be fun, because I'm going
to in the comic store
and they're going to say,
"What is she doing in here."
[ Laughs ]
>> Carla Hayden: And I'm going to
go in the comic store and I'm going
to pick out some Marvel Comics.
Any suggestions besides --
>> Gene Luen Yang: For
Marvel Comics, Ms Marvel.
>> Carla Hayden: Ms Marvel.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Ms. Marvel is great.
>> Carla Hayden: Cool.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
It's a Muslim American young girl.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Who has the
power to make any part of her body
as big or small she wants.
>> Carla Hayden: Oh, I can use that.
>> Gene Luen Yang: It's
super big, it's awesome.
>> Carla Hayden: Or super small.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And
then totally awesome hulk.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
And then DC Comics.
>> Gene Luen Yang: And then
DC, Batgirl is amazing.
It's awesome.
Batgirl, a wonderful comic and
Supergirl is also one of them.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
So do they have any
librarian comic characters?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Are there
any librarian comic characters.
There was one called the answer,
which is about a librarian
who becomes best friends
with a superhero.
>> Carla Hayden: I'm going
to look for that one too.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
>> Carla Hayden: So that's
my reading without walls.
I pledge that I will go
and get some real comics.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's great.
>> Carla Hayden: My
questions for you --
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's great.
>> Carla Hayden: -- you talked --
when we talk graphic novels,
what about nonfiction.
What do you call them, because
the novel seems to be fiction.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yes.
I [inaudible]
>> Carla Hayden: So a book
like March is graphic book?
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah, I agree.
I agree. So to answer that young
lady's question for me now a days
because I write for DC,
I'm kind of a DC guy.
But when I was a kid,
when I was your age,
I read more Marvel than DC.
But the term graphic novel is
a little bit clumsy, right.
Because we use it to describe things
that actually aren't
novels at all, like March.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: March is --
>> Carla Hayden: Is real.
>> Gene Luen Yang: -- not a novel.
It's nonfiction, it's
an autobiography.
The New York Times deals with this
by calling them graphic books
instead of gothic novels.
>> Carla Hayden: Yes.
>> Gene Luen Yang: But I do think
that the term "graphic novel,"
even though it's a little
bit, it's a little bit weird.
It refers to a publishing format.
>> Carla Hayden: Okay.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So --
>> Carla Hayden: Rather
than what type of.
>> Gene Luen Yang: --
rather than what type.
All right it looks like
we're just about out of time.
I want to thank all of you.
>> Carla Hayden: And thank you.
>> Gene Luen Yang: For [inaudible]
[applause] and those of you
who are joining us
through the cameras,
thank you so much for being here.
It was wonderful to talk to you all.
Thank you.
Thank you all so much.
>> Carla Hayden: Now who gets
to take Jeff the Weirdo home?
>> Gene Luen Yang: How are
we going to decide that?
>> Carla Hayden: I don't know.
>> Gene Luen Yang: How do we.
>> Carla Hayden: How do you do
that where you do a
thing and you [inaudible]
>> Gene Luen Yang: All right.
We'll do this.
We'll do a trivia challenge.
Somebody tell me, I've
mentioned this earlier.
Somebody tell me when
did Superman debut?
When was his first comic published?
What was his first comic published?
>> Carla Hayden: And
don't look it up.
>> Gene Luen Yang: So the young
man in the Dragonball Zee.
Do you remember?
>> 1938.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Close.
Very close, but not quite right.
Not quite right.
Okay.
>> Around the 1930s.
>> Carla Hayden: Yep.
>> Gene Luen Yang: I
want an exact year.
Go ahead young lady.
>> Carla Hayden: Exact year.
>> 1939.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Close, very close.
Very close.
Okay, over here.
Yes.
>> 1933.
>> Gene Luen Yang: No.
Very close.
>> 1939.
>> Gene Luen Yang: No.
>> Carla Hayden: In
the back over there.
>> 1931.
>> Gene Luen Yang: 1931.
Okay. Young lady right
there with the headband.
>> 19 [inaudible]
>> Gene Luen Yang: Close.
Ooh, so close, come on.
>> 1937.
>> Gene Luen Yang: That's right.
That's right.
1937.
[ Applause ]
>> Gene Luen Yang: All right.
So you get Jeff the Weirdo.
>> Carla Hayden: And you're the
one that you get Jeff the Weirdo
because you thought about
his sidekick, the cherry.
>> Gene Luen Yang: Yeah.
That's right.
You were the one that made
up the talking cherry.
>> Carla Hayden: So
you have to get that.
Thank you, Gene.
>> Gene Luen Yang:
Thank you very much.
>> Carla Hayden: Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.